والصلب بقيمة ملياري دولار.
اخلاء محطة القطارات في مدينة
العملية بينما تبحث واشنطن عن
ادلة عن دعم بكين وبيونج يانج
اغتيال رئيس وزراء باكستان
السابق عمران خان ويدعو الى تجنب
الامريكية في وجود مواد متفجرة.
البيت الابيض يدين بشدة محاولة
لدعم القضية الفلسطينية يخرج بها
العرب. فهل تنجح القمة العربية
العلاقات معها. قطر والجزائر
تفتتحان مصنعا مشتركا للحديد
القرارات الوزارية التي اصدرتها
الحكومة السابقة ستة قرارات مهمة
لموسكو في السماء. يبدو انها قد
وجدت ما تبحث عنه في الارض
العنف في السياسة. والعالم
يتساءل هل لامريكا يد في هذه
بشكل متكرر. ومن حرب التحالفات
الى حرب الرقائق. لكن فيما
الحوار. الحكومة العراقية برئاسة
محمد شياع السوداني تلغي جميع
القيم فان المنطقة برمتها ستخرج
رابحة من الدبلوماسية القائمة
تحتاج شركات التصنيع الى المزيد
من الرقائق بينما يواجه العالم
على الربح المتبادل وليس تركيا
فحسب. قال الرئيس الفلسطيني
بما فشلت به القمم السابقة?
الجيش الاسرائيلي اطلاق صاروخ من
العاهل المغربي يدعو الرئيس
الجزائري لزيارة المملكة من اجل
حثت الحكومة اليابانية السكان
على الاحتماء بعد اطلاق كوريا
في اوكرانيا واكدت ان الاتصالات
الثنائية بين فرنسا والصين ستجري
الشمالية صاروخا بحسب رويترز.
صواريخ كيم جونج اطلقها بينما
وانعكس ذلك على خطوط الانتاج
فيما تستمر الولايات المتحدة
بحربها لمنع وصول تلك الرقائق
للصينيين ما قد يحرم العالم اجمع
الاستشعار تعتمد السيارات
الحديثة على اشباه الموصلات كي
القدس. اردوجان حول التطبيع مع
اسرائيل. طالما يجري احترام
محمود عباس ان القدس تتعرض لاشرس
هجمة اسرائيلية بهدف تهويدها
مما تنتجه الصين في شتى
المجالات. الاحداث والتطورات.
الخارجية الفرنسية كاترين كولونة
محادثات مع وزير الخارجية الصيني
بهدف حماية اراضيها من التهديدات
الخارجية. يخرج رئيس الوزراء
والناتو حيث قال وزير الدفاع
الروسي سيرجي شويجو ان موسكو على
تجري اكبر مناورة عسكرية مشتركة
بالطائرات بين سيول وواشنطن عدد
للاذكى وذي النفس الاطول لتقترب
فرنسا نحو الصين حيث اجرت وزيرة
ضيفا اسرائيل لم تترك لنا خيارا
الا اعادة النظر في مجمل
الانذار. سيول اعلنت حالة
الاستنفار باطلاق ثلاثة صواريخ
علم بتفاصيل محاولات اوكرانيا
لصنع قنبلة قذرة. واكد ان الناتو
الكورية الجنوبية لاول تسبب
بحالة هلع بمقاطعة مع دوي صافرات
البريطانية لا نخطط لنقل سفارتنا
لدى اسرائيل من تل ابيب الى
وهنا بوتين تأنى قليلا. وعلق
تطبيق الاتفاق حتى اصاب الغرب
غزة باتجاه اسرائيل بعد فوز
نتنياهو في الانتخابات. الحكومة
يانج قد دعت لايقاف المناورات
المشتركة بين كوريا الجنوبية
لكن الرئيس الروسي عاد واكد ان
بلاده تحتفظ بالحق في الانسحاب
بينما يواصل الغرب رمي سهامه
الرئيس الروسي قالت صحيفة ديلي
اليوم نقصا في هذه الرقائق فان
شركات السيارات هي الاكثر تضررا
جاهزيتها للرد بحزم على اي
استفزازات. بينما كانت بيونج
جو ارض باتجاه موقع سقوط الصاروخ
الكوري الشمالي مع تأكيد
يزود اوكرانيا بمعلومات
استخبارية وانخرط في الحرب ويشن
تستخدم هذه الرقائق من عجلة
القيادة الى المكابح واجهزة
الروسية. ومن حرب نووية الى حرب
الاقتصاد. البنك الفيدرالي
رد الزعيم الكوري الشمالي واحدا.
كوريا الشمالية تطلق وابلا من
عشوائي محطة زبروجيا وهذا يهدد
بكارثة نووية بحسب الوزارة
تؤمن للسائق انتقالا امنا وكلما
تقدمنا نحو سيارة اكثر ذكاء
واشارت الى انه يتعين على باريس
وبكين توحيد الجهود انهاء النزاع
يصرح. اي هجوم نووي كوري شمالي
على بلادنا سينهي نظام كيم جونج
خطر قادم من اوكرانيا. فالدفاع
الروسية قد اعلنت ان كييف بشكل
اون. بانتظار رد المجنون جاذبية
القوة الصينية. بين اليوم
موسكو تستأنف مشاركته في اتفاق
تصدير الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود
مهول من الطائرات بما يسمى
بالعاصفة اليقظة والبنتاجون
البنكرياس. واشارت الوثائق الى
ان بوتين يتناول مسكنات كثيرة
والمستقبل يجري اعادة التحالفات
فلم يعد البقاء للاقوى فقط بل
من اتفاق الحبوب اذا اقدم الجانب
الاوكراني على انتهاك الضمانات
يا شويجو? رد كيم القوي. تتكاثر
الخطط وتزداد التدريبات. ويبقى
وواشنطن واعتبرتها استفزاز قد
يستدعي اجراءات مضادة من جانبها
الكرملين يعاني من مرحلة مبكرة
من مرض الباركنسون وسرطان
كما تقول الخارجية في روسيا هنا
سيطمئن الغرب قليلا. لكن هناك
ربما كان صاروخا باليستيا عابرا
للقارات وحلق فوق اراضينا. كما
الياباني قائلا احد الصواريخ
التي اطلقتها كوريا الشمالية
ميل البريطانية ان وثائق تجسس
مسربة من الكريملين كشفت ان زعيم
للقادة الاوروبيين تصرفاتهم
الخاطئة بحق بوتين. ليعلنها حفيد
لتصعيد التوترات في المنطقة
والتدمير النهائي للعلاقات
عثمان صراحة نعمل مع روسيا على
بناء محطة طاقة نووية ثالثة. فيا
الامريكي يعلن رفع سعر الفائدة
للمرة الرابعة على التوالي.
من ثوابت السياسة الروسية.
فاللجوء للسلاح النووي لن يكون
روسيا تبث رسالة طمأنة للغرب
مفادها منع وقوع الحرب النووية
الا لاغراض دفاعية ردا على هجوم
مماثل يهدد امن الدولة الروسية
لك من ماكر ايها العثماني بالحين
الذي تعلن فيه موسكو احباط عملية
الروسية النرويجية هذا لم يكن
اختيار موسكو حول روسيا يزداد
الشيشاني يا اصدقاء. ليحول الروس
انظارهم نحو الجارة الاخرى. وعلى
في شارع فلاديمير بوتين في
جروزني. جن جنون المصارع
موقفه ويؤيد الحوار مع بوتين.
ويضيف الرئيس التركي. شرحت
سننتهي. وسوف ندمر هذه الشيطانية
والفاشية هذا العفريت زيلنسكي
الصواريخ الباليستية تجاه جارتها
الجنوبية وصاروخ سقط قرب المياه
لتأسيس نظام دفاعي على حدود
بلاده. فكيف سيردون على كل ذلك
هذه المرة? حيث اكد نائب مندوب
الصين لدى الامم المتحدة
فهل فهم الغرب الدرس الروسي
ليعود الروس الى اتهام اوكرانيا
حرب معلومات ضد موسكو. هناك ايضا
اتهم شويجو حلف الناتو بالتخطيط
الى جروزني. لقد جهزت له منصب.
سيكون زيلنسكي كبير عمال النظافة
النهاية. هذه النهاية حسمها
قديروف مخاطبا سيليناسكي. قريبا
يطلب حوار الجزائر العرب تصدر
قرارات مهمة فهل يتم تطبيقها ام
الاستعدادات العسكرية للنرويج
بالقرب من حدودنا بمثابة مسار
فيها. بينما مجلس الامن مشروع
قرار قدمته روسيا للتحقيق في
جينشوانا ان اسئلة روسيا
الاتحادية حول انشطة المختبرات
اكثر. هنا كوريا الشمالية تقف مع
الحليف الروسي ليعلن الناطق باسم
البيولوجية الامريكية في
اوكرانيا مشروعة ويجب التحقيق
فهل يخاف الحلفاء من العقوبات
ليظهر حليف اخر لروسيا هو اقوى
مجلس الامن القومي في البيت
الابيض جون كيربي ان بيونج يانج
في مواجهة اوكرانيا. وقال كيربي
سنعمل مع حلفائنا وشركائنا في
والجميع يهرع الى الملاجئ. نعم
لقد فعلها المجنون اردوغان لاعب
بالقلق والتوتر فالمرجعة حقا هي
ما تنتظره. ليعود بوتين ويعلنها
روسيا هذه المرة ليتعالى الصراخ
الامريكي. بكين ترد بتصريح صادم
لتخفيف الم سرطان البنكرياس
والبروستات. فكيف سترد موسكو?
هذا امر عسكري ويجب ان ينفذ في
الحال. علم سيدي وجاري التنفيذ.
لكن لماذا? بينما تصدم بريطانيا
اسرائيل على غير العادة. والمغرب
بينما تستمر روسيا في خفض
الفائدة. فمن يعاقب من بعد هذا?
تخريبية اوكرانية في شبه جزيرة
القرم واعتقال منفذيها. لكن
الحلفاء واردوغان اولهم حين اعلن
ان المستشار الالماني شولتس يغير
جديد في صفوف حلفاء بوتين. فما
الذي يجري والنرويج تدوس خط
اقلق فرحة نتنياهو. نجاح الخطة
الروسية. اضغط واضغط ثم اضغط حتى
ليتهافت نحو الطرف الاقوى وفي
حرب الحلفاء الفائز من يكسب
ستبقى كسابقتها حبرا على ورق
والفلسطينيون يحتفلون بصاروخ
لتستمر حرب السياسة تحت قبة
الامم المتحدة. فمن سينتصر في
لسان المتحدثة باسم الخارجية
الروسية ماريا زخرف قائلة تعتبر
مزاعم بعدم التزام واشنطن وكييف
باتفاقية الاسلحة البيولوجية
المتحدة كي نرى اي عقوبات اضافية
يمكن فرضها على هذين البلدين.
تقدم في الخفاء مساعدة عسكرية
لروسيا بكمية كبيرة من القذائف
يتم قبول مطالبك. وان لم تقبل
فان الضغط سيولد الانفجار.
بخصوص اوكرانيا ليظهر قديروف
ويعلن النهاية. وروسيا تطمئن
بوتين الاحمر وموسكو ترد. يونج
يانج تصعد التوترات مع بخطوة في
الغرب وتبقيه يقظا في الوقت ذاته
وفرنسا تتقرب من التنين الصيني.
صواريخ المجنون تتجول في سماء
اليابان وصافرات الانذار تدوي
فبماذا سيرد كان